so then after after flash dance it's a
huge hit
right how does how does that sort of
change the trajectory of your career
and how you personally approached
everything
i had been writing between best of luck
that's right but
but after clash dance it was endless
offers and then
things coming off the the board and all
that
and then i did a series of movies in the
eighties that
that were here said jagged edge
and um and checking out which was a
little
dark comedy um that that was critically
successful
in music box you know and then then it
just went on and on from there
until basic and and all of that stuff
you know so
um you know that this is a town that
if you have a hit um you know they they
all flock to you
um but what i think is really important
as screenwriters as my brothers and
sisters screenwriting
screenwriters don't give it up just keep
keep writing keep writing keep writing
and see what happens
don't give it up you know don't don't
let them beat
your mojo out of you it's your mojo it's
your creativity
it's what you do it ain't easy when
things are made and you write this stuff
and you put your heart and soul into it
your heart and soul and your guts and
your junk and whatever you put into it
you know it's not easy but you have to
keep doing it because
from the hope and i can tell you this in
terms of my own career
you know that something will stick to
that wall that will get made
and you have a great shot you know it's
not easy
they try to beat your module you know
and a lot of people
it happens you know and and it's not
easy to to look in the base
of that kind of continuing defeat in
terms of movies being made
how many scripts at that time did you
write on spec and how many were
did the studio ask you to write um the
i've always really believed in specs for
me
and then and and and that's for me
um the the reason for that is
i don't like bitching i mean i i feel
like willie lowman at the end of the day
is selling
shoes um and
so i'd much rather write it and see what
happens to it
you know i mean i know they're very
successful screenwriters who
two or three things each day
different projects
right i can't do that then but they're
also
i think reasons of
their reasons of protection with it um
if you go in and pitch something you're
going to have
all kinds of memos and notes
from studio people and all of that if
they're interested
if you write it yourself there's less of
a chance of that happening
it's not a vertical bleed but it's more
difficult
you know they put it in the grossest
hollywood vernacular
it's more difficult for them to piss
into it
if it's all done you know and as opposed
to
ideas and things like that so i've
always i've always tried to do that and
out of the 30 subscripts that i've
written
i would say 80 90 or our original
screenplay that respect
you know that that we take out
and then see what happens now um
many of those don't work you know i
wrote a script called magic man in the
80s
about rock and roll and a disc jockey
and we took it out and nothing happened
everybody passed
um it became telling lies in america 15
years down the line
you know i wrote a script called
checking out which is dark comedy about
a man who
who suddenly has all kinds of
and and um and it's almost has a mini
nervous breakdown that didn't sell and
everybody said well this is
really bleak and dark and it's never
going to get made and in fact it never
did
except 10 years down the line george
harrison's company read it
bought it um and made it you know
that very well jeff daniels that the
movie didn't work
yeah but they made it you know so you
never know you never know what comes out
of the walls
um and i've always believed in that or
what i've always really believed in
is right to take it from your heart and
your soul
and then let god decide what's going to
happen to it in some ways